yeah well come to a couple of new Blitz
videos first game for today so i hope
i'm not that rusty the first game is
always difficult very rare line but it's
not that bad try to set up a centre with
t4 it's interesting g6 looks a bit weird
to combine the night a5 approach with g6
but maybe it's playable what about Queen
d4 here could that be uncomfortable
looks very strange let f 6 i'm i play a
five
and pawn to f6 looks very ugly yeah
played it anyway okay
do I have something better than let's
say just castles could go h4 plusher
direct h4 h5 might see thick lab play
just 23 let's try this okay and you to
drop this back okay think it should be a
good position for the Queen relatively
speaking looking at g6 maybe if the h5
this could be a very sensitive spot
alright wife is very very ugly moved to
face what torture to play now
it's not easy
maybe Bishop h6 something like this try
to exchange this don't know I don't see
a really good move okay just developing
a KH 5s are the obvious move of course
but what now just threaten yeah petardas
ecover g6 if i take here exchange here
then he 5 g 6 is just just a terribly
weak spot I could play a five-year of
calls
so should I just develop further think
so
yeah but this is also very ugly e5 okay
once played d5 if I love it but right
now still g6 would be hanging
somewhat hard to believe
okay it just opens it up with his King
in the center and everything okay let's
try this I can take on e4 or with the
piece because of the pin at upland Queen
h12 h7 maybe need to be quick here yeah
it's still rather complicated very hard
to believe that black and play like this
but
I don't think you can really take here
the 95 threat night c5 Bishop g5 all
kinds of moves maybe can play deform yam
but then I just thought a night be three
would be good okay can can take on a two
but now I can can capture d5 with d 6
and so on
cake now and I need to speed up a bit he
might have hired me on this one oops
mostly I wanted to play d7 of course I
awful yeah this was just fine for white
but okay
okay let's see if I can still get
something going Queen d3 if Jay can just
play King King c6 or something very
lucky play just from there yeah this is
just lost i don't have any play you
cannot do much
terrible losses he played us like a
complete [ __ ] sorry but absolutely
absolutely unbelievable
at least is slow check
check check check check
check Chuck maybe I even got some
chances there in the mid life there's
the middle of the mess yeah of course I
didn't want to take yeah this was after
d7 white is just clearly better whatever
let's just check quickly but Sadie 7
what's the comp giving plus 3 year it's
it's just just awful awful for black if
it takes then we need one Queen age 7
this is maybe just to mate somewhere um
he was basically um clearly worse after
the opening and only thing that could
happen was a set this ma slip here yeah
ok next game hopefully without some some
crazy mouse action